THIS, YOU DON'T NEED A THREE.
YOU NEED A TWO.
I WOULD GO AT THE RIM.
VALUE EITHER WAY, THEY WILL SEND
YOU TO THE LINE.
IONESCU, ELENI, YOU WANT TO SEE
THEM WITH THE BALL.
CHRIS: BALL INBOUND TO KYLEE
SHOOK.
4 SECONDS LEFT.
LONG THREE FOR THE WIN.
SHE GETS IT.
IONESCU AT THE BUZZER.
.4 SECONDS LEFT.
SABRINA IONESCU FROM DOWNTOWN.
THE LIBERTY HAVE A THREE-POINT
LEAD.
MY GOODNESS.
JULIANNE: WE'VE GOT OURSELVES A
BALLER ON THE NEW YORK LIBERTY.
SHE IS A GAMETIME CLUTCH PLAYER.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A CLUTCH SHOT
THAT IS SO SAD, SO HER.
IN COLLEGE, SHE TURNS, SHE SETS
HER BE SO NICE.
THE BENCH LOVES IT.
CHRIS: VICTORIA VIVIANS'S FACE
ON THE FEVER BENCH.
JULIANNE: SHE IS TRYING NOT TO
SMILE.
CHRIS: IF WE CAN GET ANOTHER
LOOK AT THE REPLAY.
JULIANNE: THAT WAS PRETTY.
CHRIS: SABRINA IONESCU, ICE IN
HER VEINS, .4 LEFT.
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE TRENT
TUCKER RULE.
5-01 TO END THE GAME BY IONESCU.
TIFFANY MITCHELL FOR THREE FOR
THE TIE.
NO GOOD.
THE LIBERTY WIN THE SEASON
OPENER HERE AT BARCLAYS CENTER
BY THREE.
THANKS TO IONESCU.
ICE IN HER VEINS AS SHE KNOCKS
IT DOWN, FINISHES WITH 21
POINTS, 11 ASSISTS, SIX
REBOUNDS, FOUR SHY OF A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
THEY COMBINE TO SCORE 55 OF THE
LIBERTIES 90 POINTS.
JULIANNE: THIS IS KIND OF A
TRANSCENDENT STAR THAT GOES SO
WELL IN NEW YORK.
THE BIGGEST MARKET IN THE WNBA.
A BEAUTIFUL SHOT.
AND THIS PLAY.
I LOVE THIS PLAY.
THIS DRAWL UP.
IT WAS REALLY KIND OF EXPECTED
WHO WOULD SEE THE BASKETBALL.
SHE TOOK CARE OF BUSINESS.
CHRIS: TRYING TO GET SABRINA --
CAN YOU HEAR US?
>> YES I CAN.
CHRIS: WHAT IS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN YOU TAKE THAT
LAST SHOT?
>> I WANTED IT.
HIGH HAVEN'T PLAYED IN A WHILE.
I WANTED IT FOR THIS TEAM.
JUST SO HAPPY TO HAVE FANS AND
FAMILY IN ATTENDANCE.
JUST THE BEGINNING FOR US.
JULIANNE: DESCRIBE THIS FIRST
GAME BACK.
10, 11 MONTHS SINCE YOU HAVE
SEEN THE COURT.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU FELT SO
COMFORTABLE.
>> I'M EXCITED TO GET BACK TO
PLAYING AND DO WHAT I LOVE.
MY TEAM SUPPORTED ME, MY
COACHING STAFF, THIS IS WHAT I
LOVE DOING.
THE HIGHS, THE LOWS, EVERYTHING
REALLY PAYS OFF.
JULIANNE: TALK ABOUT THE WAY
THAT PRESEASON HAS BEEN FOR YOU.
THIS HAS BEEN A NEWER TEAM,
NEWER LINEUP.
WHAT IS IT LIKE PLAYING WITH
SOMEONE LIKE ELIJAH LANEY WHO
YOU CAN GO TO AT ANY MOMENT?
>> SHE PLAYED UNBELIEVABLE, I
THINK EVERYONE DID.
WE NEEDED EVERYONE TONIGHT.
SHE IS A PHENOMENAL PLAYER.
PLAYING AGAINST HER WAS TOUGH.
I AM HAPPY SHE IS ON OUR TEAM.
CHRIS: TWO WINS LAST YEAR FOR
THIS TEAM, YOU ONLY PLAYED THREE
GAMES.
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
GETTING THIS OUT-OF-THE-WAY?
>> WE NEEDED THIS.
IN FRONT OF THE FANS, EVERYBODY
HERE.
I HAVEN'T WON A PART OF THIS
ORGANIZATION GOING DOWN LAST
YEAR, SO THIS WILL BE SPECIAL.
THERE IS A LOT MORE COMING FOR
US.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE ARE GOING TO STEP ASIDE AND
TAKE A BREAK, BUT WE WILL COME
BACK TO WRAP THINGS UP.
ANOTHER LOOK AT THE HERO FOR THE
NEW YORK LIBERTY.
SABRINA IONESCU.
JULIANNE: SABRINA IS FEELING IT.
SHE LOVED BEING BACK OUT THERE.
THE JOY OF THE GAME FLOWS
THROUGH HER VEINS.